Donald Trump received some of his best polling
in a while yesterday.
There's a major new poll from CNN which has
Joe Biden only four points ahead of Donald
Trump with the margin of error.
That could mean Trump is now straight up winning.
This is one of the closest polls in a while.
It's not the only one that says the race is
this close, but it should be a huge warning
to anybody who thinks Joe Biden has this in
the bag, especially if you thought yesterday's
first day of the DNC was not so good.
Then we have nothing to sit back and be complacent
about if we look at recent national polls.
CNN now has Biden only plus four, and otherwise
it's a bunch of Biden plus seven, Biden plus
nine, Biden plus 10.
Other than a Harris sex poll from a week ago,
which agrees it's Biden up by four.
Now, if we look at this CNN poll more closely,
you will see that the margin of error is three
point seven.
OK, so that means that the poll says that
this is not speculation.
Instead of 50.
Biden might only have forty six point three
instead of 46.
Trump could have forty nine point seven.
So this poll, if you read it correctly and
understand the margin of error, the poll says
that right now Trump could be up by three
point four.
Now, I don't need to remind you that in 2016,
Hillary Clinton had a lead of three in the
national polls and she ended up winning by
two.
From the standpoint of the popular vote and
lost the Electoral College, as Michelle Obama
astutely pointed out yesterday, this is a
poll which says, forget about whether Biden
is up three or four.
Trump could be up three nationally right now.
This poll outlines a better situation for
Donald Trump today than he had in November
of 2016.
Now it's one poll.
The average lead for Biden remains just under
eight points.
But why would we take any chance?
The polling is looking more and more like
it did in 2016.
Anyone thinking this is over needs to check
the facts.
And the facts are that not only is the polling
tightening between Biden and Trump, Trump's
approval is climbing.
I know that when we think about facts and
reason, it is crazy to think that this would
be going on.
But we live in a country where more than 60
million people voted for the guy in 2016.
So we have to expect things that make no sense.
And if you look at the Gallup Trump approval
tracking poll, you see that after a huge drop
in approval during the earlier phases of the
Corona virus pandemic, Donald Trump's approval
has slowly but surely started to creep back
up from a low of 38 back in whenever up to
39, 40, 42.
And the trend is pointing further up.
Now we can debate why this is happening.
Some people are falling for Trump's B.S.
They're just falling for it.
We have a crazy situation that has been normalized
to some degree.
And people have gotten used to the pandemic
and used to thousands of people dying every
single week from Corona virus.
There are some people that are just dumb.
Okay.
Oh, find that's some beat.
It doesn't matter.
That's the thing.
They get to vote and we get to vote.
Our focus needs to be getting out the vote
and making sure that we vote.
This is not it.
If you looked at Biden plus fifteen and an
outlier polls six weeks ago and thought this
was going to be easy.
This is not going to be easy.
Two and a half months to go.
We could see anything happen between now and
November.
Trump teasing.
He's going to pardon someone major today.
Who knows what that is.
He mentioned it.
He said it's not Snowden today, but he's now
thinking about.
We don't know how different elements of the
electorate could react.
We have no control over it.
We only have control over our voting and talking
to other people about the importance of voting.
Let me know where you are on this polling
issue on Twitter, where you can find me at
Deas Pacman.
And remember that August twenty third is the
15th anniversary of the David Pakman show
on that very special day.
We will be sending out a coupon code via our
newsletter with an insane, possibly illegal,
certainly immoral membership discount that
you can take advantage of.
Just get on our newsletter free at David Pakman
dot com.